alors Monsieur Philippe Lejeune est avec
nous avant de parler de du journal
intime avec Jacques Chancel un
spécialiste qui le vit de l'intérieur un
amoureux aussi surtout et bien Philippe
lejeun j'aimerais que vous nous
racontiez vous êtes l'initiateur donc de
ce de ce salon de de cette exposition
quelle
idée ben il s'ag oui c'est une idée
bizarre il s'agissait de d'aller contre
des préjugés et des ignorances comme
Jacques Chanet j'ai moi-même tenu un
journal intime j'en tiens un et nous
avons l'impression peutêtre d'être
méconnu euh les choses qu'on dit souvent
sur le journal intime d'abord c'est que
ça ça n'existe plus aujourd'hui ça se
faisait autrefois les jeunes filles du
19e siècle alors ce qu'on a voulu
montrer c'est que ça se fait aujh vous
n'avez rien de jeunes fill du 19e siècle
tous les deux hein non mais ça se fait
encore aujourd'hui et ça s'est beaucoup
fait hier le journal de Jules Renard le
journal de Gide aujourd'hui le journal
de sioran il y a le blog no de François
moriac et le journal de Julien Green
mais il y a écrire et publierier hein
oui mais écrire tout seul se fait de
plus en plus et je crois que c'est lié à
la l'augmentation de la scolarisation
des adolescents beaucoup d'adolescents
sont maintenus maintenant à l'école
jusqu'à 16 ans ils ont des cahiers et
ils sont encore à l'écart de la vie
active ils se cherchent ils cherchent
leur identité et je crois que donc du
côté des inédits il y a beaucoup plus de
journaux tenus que mais c'est quand même
un énorme défi parce que vous allez dans
l'intimité des gens Jacques Chancel le
disait il y a une différence entre
écrire et publié là les gens qui ont
écrit pour eux sans idée de le montrer
d'un seul coup acceptent de de le
dévoiler oui euh ils acceptent d'abord
il y a des journaux du passé donc les
journaux sont dans les archives où ils
ont été publiés ça n'est plus intime et
puis ils acceptent parce que en fait ils
comprennent le sens de l'exposition qui
est non pas de violer leur intimité à
eux mais de montrer que le journal est
une chose respectable euh beaucoup de
préjugés sur le journal on pense que
c'est puérich que c'est féminin que
c'est n brilque narcissique je sais pas
quels sont tous les autres objectifs
qu'on peut dire et en nous prêtant leur
journal qui est présenté je crois avec
dignité et respect euh ben ils espéraent
comme nous que c'est une autre idée
d'intimité quielle être donné alors
c'est vrai que le journal euh entre dans
un cercle narcissique pour beaucoup de
gens d'ailleurs si on regarde le journal
de Julien Green mais bravo c'est Julien
Green c'est tout à fait extraordinaire
d'avoir un peu les petites minutes de sa
vie mais moi je dois dire que j'écris
deux journaux j'ai le journal intime que
je ne publirai jamais et puis j'ai le
journal de mes jours et bien écoutez je
vais vous proposer un reportage sur une
jeune femme